morning welcome to the executive session
of the house criminal justice and Public
Safety Committee if you please rise and
join me for the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
the repic stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all thank you and we are beginning our
executive session this morning um I'm
going to open the executive session on
on HB
1113 and I recognize representative
Manion to make a
motion thank you Mr chair uh I make a
motion uh ought to pass on House Bill
13113 is there a second I'll second
seconded by represent Pro uh would you
like to speak to your motion I would
thank you um we discussed this uh at
length over the past few months and I
know there's a lot of concern with our
police officer still remaining
physically fit however uh I've been in
law enforcement for over 30 years this
bill doesn't affect me either way um but
I was here pre 2001 when this bill went
into effect and clearly after that
so it's my understanding the initial
reason for this bill was to reduce
injuries on officers however I I've seen
no evidence that that has done that so
um some of the reasons why I think that
this bill should pass and that should be
repealed
is
um the standard we use is Cooper
standards so it doesn't really
differentiate between ages and genders
for example a 59y old male would have to
do the mile and a half run six seconds
slower than an 18-y old female um it's
an outdated system uh I've spoken with a
lot of law enforcement officers and
police Chiefs in my area and most of
them agree that there should be a
different standard however they also
agree that they should be controlled by
the town and not be tied to a
certification so one of the biggest
problems with this is it's tied to your
certification so if you fail this uh
you're given a second chance on it but
if if you fail it by 10 seconds on the
run or a couple of push-ups here and
there you lose your certification you
lose your career you can't work in New
Hampshire anymore um so a lot of towns
are of the mindset that they'd like to
just have their own standard that the
department can have and if if you don't
pass it it doesn't affect your career or
your
certification another reason why is
there are a lot of out ofate um retired
offices from Massachusetts new uh in
Maine and Connecticut that come up here
to work a second career there's a lot of
experience uh that would Ling because
they just don't want to come here and
have to do that that Physical Agility
testing you're not paid to train for
this test so while you're out running
and doing your push-ups and sit-ups
getting ready for this test you're not
being paid to do that in addition if you
get hurt while you're doing that you're
probably not going to get covered by
work with comp I've seen examples of
that in my career um and then you can't
pass it test because now you're injured
so you have to you fail it and you have
to wait for your second chance at
it uh most PDS already have an incentive
based Physical Agility Test on the towns
that I've worked for do so if you pass
it there's a money stien that you would
get for it um but they don't pay that on
the year that you're required to do it
this would still be in place if you're
being hired the standard would still be
there to get into the academy to
graduate from the academy as it was
prior to 2001 that will still remain in
effect there just won't be a three-year
requirement for officers to do that
um in the 20 plus years we've been doing
it zero states have adopted our our
model there are no other states in the
country that do this other than New
Hampshire and in New Hampshire there's
only one agency that does and that's the
police departments we don't require of a
firefighters or EMTs or any other agency
just our police offices so um I think
it's time to help with our
Recruitment and retaining Offices here
and being able to get the best Minds out
there without having to worry about a
Physical Agility test every three years
leave it up to the towns let's not make
a state mandate I so I my I'm going to
be voting uh yes on ought to pass on
this thank you representative um per
would you like to speak to your
second sure just a little bit uh I did
talk to a couple of police Chiefs as
well and uh they were in favor of this
going away because they've lost some
really good talent and experience
because the day of the test someone had
a injured Ang ankle or something like
that and and again they failed so they
couldn't and it was going to be too long
before their ankle got fixed uh for them
to take the test again or they had to do
it in a certain amount of time and it
and it just didn't uh so they lost that
person and again right now uh seems like
the
uh younger population doesn't want to
come into these jobs so getting uh a
freshly retired guy from another state
with a lot of experience and is willing
to work it it we have to make that more
desirable uh the pension system is a
mess so uh that's a deterrent so we
don't need any more deterrence like they
have to um meet this standard that's
kind of outdated and I agree the town
should be making their own um and not
the
state thank you um I would I would just
say that um um for me personally I was
originally um on the other side of that
I thought that the standard was it was
appropriate to have a state standard um
having said that I I spoke to a number
of people um it seems that the chiefs of
Police Association was kind of split
50/50 on this as well and I think when
in doubt revert to the um to the local
authorities they know they're hiring
they know their their standards what
they need um the local community is
still free to set a PT standard um this
does not take away PT standards it just
says the state's not going to mandate it
it's now would be up to the local um
departments and the state police to have
their own standards and I think that's
highly appropriate given as we just
discussed it is very difficult to fill
positions within the police department
now and given these standards and other
issues it's very tough to get people to
come here from another state or even get
interested in it in the first place when
when they know that every 3 years
they'll have to take this test
regardless of what happens in their life
um at the state level we don't know
what's going on with an individual
officer um with regard to his health
what he's been through um what's
happened on the job whereas the local
Chief will know okay this guy has been
involved in some stuff he's he got hurt
um they can wave it locally but at the
state level it becomes more difficult
and complicated and having it tied to
their
certification as um representative
Manion said if they fail they can't work
anywhere else in New Hampshire we've
literally just kicked them out of the
state and I don't think that's right I
think that should be a local decision
and it should not be tied to their
certification and remember it's still
mandatory Statewide to get into the
academy and to graduate from the academy
once they get employed full-time at a
department then it's up to the
department what physical fitness
standards they choose to use for their
um employees and they could even even
follow a model made by standards and
training if they wished further
comments go
ahead
thank I just have a question with um
when someone comes from out of state
who's say a retired police officer from
Connecticut um do they still go to our
police academy or is there a a license
um like does a transfer there policing
ability I just I just don't understand
the process I I believe that um they
have to take a um if they have
experience and they've gone to the
academy I believe they had to take a law
class on the Hampshire laws but their um
their training is accepted I believe um
train transfer wise they don't have to
go through the academy
again is that correct go ahead that is
correct but they're still required to do
that three-year physical fitness test
even though they didn't attend the full
Academy further questions comments
represent
wheeler well Mr chairman I appreciate
what representative Manion and yourself
has said I I I think that it's more I
have more of an inclination rather than
when in doubt uh blow up the system to
say when in doubt leave it alone I think
that New Hampshire's police system right
now as it stands works well and we heard
in the subcommittee that I was able to
sit on that dealt with this
bill our system is actually lotted and
excuse me congratulated as heralded
across the country as uh better than
most because of our standards and I
think if we get rid of those standards
then we risk having police officers that
aren't necessarily able to do the job as
hard as it is I think if we want to
retain our police officers or increase
the Staffing changes which I think is a
valid concern then we should pay them
more uh young people aren't getting into
the workforce in this industry and in a
lot of other Industries because of the
pay and the cost of living which has
exponentially increased over the last so
many years and I think that we should
deal with that issue rather than
lowering the standard to try and retain
people who wouldn't necessarily be able
to do the job to their full ability and
on the sub committee I thought we had
had um some agreement despite
representative manion's descent and I
would hope that uh this bipartisan
effort that happened in subcommittee can
continue to happen and that we can vote
against the aop pass motion to make
another motion so that we can continue
to have these good standards that are
congratulated Across the Nation as some
of the best for police so I will be
voting against the aop pass Motion in
the hopes of another motion being made
thank you representative um all all good
points I would however say that um it
may be lauded and congratulated but it's
not emulated no one else has um found it
so good that they wanted to do it
themselves um and also um I I trust our
local police Chiefs to decide whether or
not a person is fit enough in their
Community to um continue in the job but
I think that reasonable Minds can
disagree um further comment
representative
m
so during the initial testimony we heard
from uh from uh John skippa uh who's the
head of New Hampshire police standards
and training um one of the things that
he told us is basically 95% of the
people who take this test pass it uh
there aren't a lot of officers uh who
fail it uh and in the past three years
uh there have been 15 officers uh uh in
in three years who've actually been uh
suspended because they can't pass this
test you know part of the issue in front
of us is you know what we're asking
police standards and training to do and
and it's actually to create standards
and training around things like this
requirements for police officers um the
requirements uh as as we understand it
um uh and and I think as uh uh as
representative wheeler uh pointed
out uh New Hampshire's program and and
the fact that that we do this uh is
something that uh that other states are
actually trying to replicate right now
um I I also think one of the things that
we need to uh that we need to uh to
focus a little bit more on uh also is
just the fact that the the the there's
so much disagreement uh within the New
Hampshire Chiefs of police uh themselves
about this and so what we're doing right
now um if we pass the this bill is we're
actually taking the most radical step we
can which is to eliminate the
requirements Al together and I think one
of the things that director skippa was
asking us to do was to try to find a way
to help them evolve the requirements um
one of the things that we talked about
in uh in subcommittee was the idea of
actually establishing uh for for example
for someone who is who uh an officer who
who can't meet the standards because of
some type of
of disability or injury um uh having an
an alternative way that they could
actually complete uh the requirements so
for instance participation uh in some
type of a wellness program that would be
approved by police standards and
training but but I think I I one of the
reasons why I'm going to oppose this is
because this is a this is a very radical
step uh to get rid of something uh
altogether when it just seems seems like
there's so much room to take uh an
intermediary step that that actually
might achieve both both goals um you
know to maintain a certain level of
Fitness among New Hampshire uh police
officers while respecting the fact that
yeah some of them are getting older some
of them are injured uh it's not as easy
to do this uh when you're older uh as
when you're younger I mean these these
are all valid arguments um but I I I
just urge caution uh before we just
throw this out completely which is what
this bill would
do thank you further questions uh
representa PR comments I guess I have a
my first question that pops up in my
head is what states are trying to
emulate us because I don't know of any
um I had another one
um I hate that when that happens
um yeah senior moments I hate those and
I can't finish but um well now I have to
change my vote You just prove that he
was right and people getting older next
time I'll write it
down and representative uh
Khan thank you Mr chairman uh Ser
serving as a selectman for 15 years in
my town I know that how hard to find or
hire a police officer especially the
parttime police officer is extremely
hard and I was I I didn't have any
knowledge that we are the last state
that holding this
rules
uh and also I heard that the town and
cities will have the responsibility to
set a standard Mr chairman is is very
good idea to go this way and I'll vote
Yes you know when it comes
time thank you for sharing that
experience represent f is recall this
question all right well and I remember
uh when we were talking to uh director
Skipper that they had been working on
changing this um standard for years and
nothing has ever come they said they've
been working on it nothing ever comes
because they understand it's kind of too
strict and they've been working on
trying to fix it but they never do so um
this is our chance to fix it
thank
you represent wheeler just thank you Mr
chairman has director skippa asked the
committee or the legislature to repeal
the standards I I don't think so and I I
I think that direct to skippa actually
probably likes the standards if he
hasn't asked to repeal them because he
does have the leeway to come before us
and ask with all due respects if we want
to repeal the standards and and and I I
think if he wants to work with us to fix
the standards he absolutely can I like
what representative Muse said I think
this is a a far too radical step when we
can take an intermediate step to be
proactive if we want to be
representative Peru and fix these
standards to a way that would be
sufficient to maintain the workforce and
have physically fit police
officers well in in all due respect to
uh rep uh to um director skippa he
doesn't uh write laws we do and another
representative did bring this law
forward for us to vote on and consider
and there was um there was good reason
for him to do so so I think that as I
said um earlier
um like Minds we can disagree on on
whether or not this is necessary at the
state or local level I think we all
agree it's level it's necessary at some
level we just disagree on who should be
the one in charge of it and I feel that
it should be a local decision based on
their knowledge of the people and their
Community um having said that um
representative Stone thank you Mr chair
I like to point out that in 1999 I heard
from Lieutenant Skipper at the time who
said he was working on looking at a new
uh testing other than the Cooper
standard well as you're aware we're now
into 2023 and the Cooper standard Still
Remains at the police academy I think
you also need to put into perspective
that in 1999 that the retirement system
for the New Hampshire police was 20
years now that has changed to 25 years
and 55 so what was once thought as a
process to go forward to improve our
police officers kind of got kicked along
the way when the retirement got
increased where in the area I live in we
see a lot of officers that occasionally
will end up not doing well with the PT
standards and they go right over to
Vermont where they don't have to do it
and they're getting similar pay so from
a recruitment standard as uh
representative Manion said we are going
to be getting a lot of the 55 56 year
old police officers that retire from
Connecticut or Massachusetts coming to
New Hampshire where we have tax you know
tax-free income they're going to not go
here because of the one reason is they
don't want to take a PT test every 3
years as they get to their golden years
it's just very uh you know and for a
small community they should set their
standards Nash could set their standards
Manchester kin clamont Newport each
small community should be able to set
their own standards right now a lot of
them have collective bargaining that are
in play and this is a part of it where
they receive a monetary incentive for
completing the PT test so I think that
needs to be also considered when voting
on this issue yeah thank you that is a
good point collective bargaining does
play a role in this where um a state
level mandate is difficult um you have
to Collective bargain around it kind of
um versus with it so it's it's
definitely there's definitely pluses and
minuses on both sides and um I trust
everyone will make their own decision
based on their their knowledge and
experience and what they've heard with
that um I will ask the clerk to call the
role the motion on the floor is ought to
pass
representative Stone yes representative
Maser yes representative Pratt yes
representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative Khan yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative tenar yes Representative
gther no representative muse no
representative
Vale no representative Sue Newman no
representative Murphy no representative
Ray Newman no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no Representative
selig no representative wheeler no
chairman Roy chair vs yes motion is
1010 is there a um so the the motion
failed else um is there another motion
on the floor represent wheeler thank you
Mr chairman I'd like to motion itl on HB
1113 and is there a
second seconded by represent
M um I don't think we need further
discussion um unless you want to having
said that um we'll call the role on that
motion representative Stone no
representative Maser no representative
Pratt no representative scitec
representative PR no representative con
no representative
Manion no representative Reed no
Representative tanzar no representative
gther yes representative Muse yes
representative Vale yes representative
Su Newman yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative celik yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes no
motion is 1010 that motion fails as well
um it will go to the floor with no
recommendation um I believe the um the
motion before the house will start off
with
OTP um who will be writing The Minority
Report U representative wheeler actually
it's not minority it's the the tibo
report
for your side and um represent manual
will write it I need those reports no
later than tomorrow they have to go to
the clerk um by
tomorrow and with that the executive
session on
hb13
oh yes
sir uh parliamentary question after uh
UT to pass failed why was itl necessary
if it failed
also um so that yeah someone could have
changed their mind you're when one
motion fails it's open automatically to
further motions and the other only other
motion available was
that um I think the point of your
question is why do it if we knew the
outcome I think uh yeah it's it's just
the way it works anyway the um executive
session on HB 1113 is closed and I'm
opening the executive session on
HB 144 and I repres recognize
representative Stone to make a motion
thank you Mr chair I make a motion for
itl on HB 144 FN is there a
second seconded by representative PR
would you like to speak to your motion
representative
Stone Mr chair I would uh currently
under state law there's an analment
process that would address the issues
brought forth in this uh this house bill
uh under that it has jurisdiction over
state level offenses uh likewise if the
intent was to try to have a jurisdiction
over Federal felonies that wouldn't be
applicable to us therefore uh majority
of the committee felt itl was an
appropriate
motion would you like to speak to your
second
Representative no I think he wrapped
that up quite nicely indeed um I would
add to that I just um the with with all
that's going on in our society in our
debate back and forth uh on gun laws and
gun safety um I I am happy to to see
that this committee will not be
supporting returning Firearms to felons
um I think that's the last thing we need
to even be considering um so with that
any further
comment seeing none I'd ask clerk to
call the rooll motion on the floor is oh
excuse me
itl representative Stone yes
representative Maser yes representative
Pratt yes representative zc yes
representative PR yes representative KH
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
tanzar yes representative gather yes
representative Muse yes representative
Vale yes representative Su Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes vote is
20 any objection to
consent seeing none it will go on the
consent
calendar with that I close the executive
session on HB
144 um just for the committee's um
purposes as you go on the list I'm going
to be skipping over and we're going to
take care of all the bail bills at the
end so we're going to go right on to to
House Bill 344 I open the executive
session and I recognize representative
gathri to make a
motion that's the
Cannabis
yes um I moved to
itl uh HB
344 and I
second would you like to speak to your
motion yeah somewhat um
we believe that um this would be in
violation um of federal laws because
there are folks that um are under
Housing Authority which is part of the
federal government and so they we they
would be in violation period with
federal laws by um allowing cultivations
in um their apartments or their
homes thank you um I think you said that
well I I agree that um we we we are
struggling to pass a comprehensive
cannabis um position in this state and I
don't think nibbling at it from the
sides this way is appropriate it's going
to have unintended consequences such as
what you listed um potentially people
losing their homes that are federally um
subsidized and we have a hard enough
problem finding homes for everyone in
this state and we don't need to be doing
anything that could shrink them further
comment seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role the motional floor is
itl representative Stone yes
representative
maer sorry yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec representative PR
yes representative Khan yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative tanzar yes
representative gather yes representative
Muse yes represent representative Vale
yes representative Su Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
suig yes representative wheeler no
chairman Roy chair vots yes vote is
does anyone object to
consent okay if it can I'm not sure if
it can or it can't but we're going to
say it goes on consent if it can't then
um we'll discuss that at later I'll find
out today um will anyone like to write a
Minority
Report or just let your vote
speak what's that you will okay I can
you know represent realer will
right
um with that I will close CL the
executive session on House Bill
344 and we will take up House Bill 470
and I recognize representative tenar to
make a motion thank you Mr chair I make
a motion of itl on House Bill 470 is
there a second I'll second that seconded
by representative Reed would you like to
speak to your motion uh yes briefly
thank you Mr chair uh I was on the fence
with this originally I was a chair of
the subcommittee uh however speaking
with law enforce fellow colleagues and
constituents uh I am moving forward
again with the with the itl motion House
Bill 287 uh the Fentanyl and xylazine
test drift was just signed into law by
the governor I think that's a great
start let's see what we can get from
statistics based off of that and then
move forward possibly with this bill in
the next session or
so thank you would you like to speak to
your second representa re yes um states
that have enacted similar laws such as
Oregon have started to withdraw a work
on repealing their um laws because they
are failing in the cities that rolled
them out thank you do you have any
information as to why or or any more
anything other than that um overto it
didn't it hasn't reduced um overdose
deaths actually overdose deaths have
increased and um it has not reduced the
number of people who are suffering from
substance misuse disorder um it has um
affected the quality of life in the
communities in which um these laws are
act enacted um and it has just not been
successful on any
level representative
Muse yes um I'll be opposing the itl and
I have to say I'm a little bit surprised
because in our subcommittee we actually
voted out to pass uh with Amendment on
this uh so the fact that we're facing an
itl vote is a little bit of an
unpleasant surprise this morning um but
one of the things that I I I do want to
point out are the the rationale for
putting uh putting this bill forward so
the currently the situation that we're
in in New Hampshire is every time some
type of new drug checking technology
comes out like a fentanyl test strip or
xylazine test strips the position
position we're in right now is we
actually have to change our statute to
uh to accommodate that so one of the
things that that this bill and the
amendment that we prepared to this bill
would would do is actually get us out of
that situation it would also get us out
of a similar situation with no lockone
um n lockone right now is the only
opioid reversal agent that's actually
approved in statute for use in New
Hampshire there are a series of new
opioid reversal a agents that are coming
uh into the market now and that have
been tested uh that have been shown to
be more effective on car Fentanyl and
Fentanyl so so one of the things that is
such a challenge with the opioid
epidemic right now is to is to stay
ahead of it um and I think law
enforcement has done uh a a very good
job in in reducing the flow as much as
they can uh but as hard as the folks in
law enforcement work and as much as the
rest of us hope that this problem would
just go away we remain in a
situation where dozens of people
continue to die from overdoses uh in New
Hampshire and not only are people dying
from
overdoses um because a lot of the
chemicals uh that are in the pills and
in the powders uh that people buy on the
street uh don't necessarily contain the
drug that people think they're buying a
lot of times folks are in a situation
where they're taking something they
absolutely um have no idea they're
putting into their body so that that's
the situation uh that we learned about
earlier in the year uh with xylazine
um and currently there's a similar
situation in the New Hampshire drug
Supply with uh
benzodiazapine uh as well as l lol so
both of those drugs are basically being
used by drug manufacturers they they can
uh increase uh the temporary high from
drugs uh like like cocaine and like
opioids you know unfortunately um one of
the things that benzo dipine uh uh can
also do uh is it can lead to uh the same
sort of sores the same sort of uh um uh
injuries that um that doctors are seeing
uh with the use of
xylazine so the the problem that we
we're running into is that this is um a
whack-a-mole situation um these new
adulterants and contaminants are coming
up um faster than we can detect them and
one of the advantages of having a
broader more robust uh drug checking
program is we actually able to collect
more data about when and where these new
contaminants and adulterants are coming
into the market so States uh States like
Massachusetts that have a more robust
drug checking program they know when
these contaminants are coming into
places like LOL and Lawrence they know
where they're coming in they know who's
buying them and what it does is it puts
law enforcement in a situation where
they're more informed they know what's
happening on the street they know they
know that there's something out there
dangerous in addition to these drugs
this is how we kind of got into the
fenal mess in the first place there so
many people thought they were taking
regular opioids and what they what they
wound up taking were opioids Lac with
fenel or pure
fenel so what we're what we're trying to
do here isn't to get in the way of law
enforcement doing its job what we're
trying to do is we're trying to do um
something that a lot of times isn't in
our power as legislators we're actually
trying to save lives and bills like this
will save lives they put us in a better
situation in the future um when it comes
uh to uh accommodating new technologies
um that can detect some of these drugs
and new contaminant more efficiently and
effectively and uh and and and it gives
uh you know people in the harm reduction
Community some of the ammunition that
they need to do their jobs right now
we've we're in a situation where we've
legalized fentanyl test strips but we
haven't necessarily made it legal for
the for people who might be giving
fental test strips to people to actually
possess those fentanyl test strips and
the minor amount of drugs that may be on
those fentanyl test strips so under our
current law it's actually conceivable uh
for a person who's actually handing out
these these uh test strips as part of a
of a of a drug checking exercise if
those if those test strips are actually
uh used and left with them um they can
actually be charged with a crime so
there there are just a bunch of things
that we need to do other than say
fentanyl test strips and xylazine test
strips are okay there's work that needs
to take place in the statute and this
the amendment that we prepared to this
bill actually accommodates a lot of that
and what it also did and and what it
what it would do is it it it it it
acknowledges the concerns of law
enforcement uh so originally the the uh
the bill uh would have simply crossed
out testing and analyzing equipment from
the drug paraphernalia statute so one of
the things that we heard from law
enforcement is GE don't do that because
testing and analyzing equipment is also
used in manufacturer distribution um and
compounding of some of these drugs so we
don't want to give drug manufacturers a
license to use this equipment and and
that's absolutely perfectly fair so what
we've done is we've left that part of
the statute intact and we've created a
specific exemption just for drug
checking equipment like these test
strips that's that's basically what this
bill uh what this bill is doing is we're
creating a a a a clear uh a clear
exemption that does not get in the way
of law enforcement from enforce
enforcing this law and
um while we can always submit a bill
like this in the next session I think
that there are probably several hundred
people out there uh who may not be with
us by the time we might get around
passing this bill who might be with us
if we actually passed it so there is a
cost to not passing a bill like this and
and I would ask my fellow committee
members to think long and hard above
that cost in the middle of of a fental
epidemic thank you thank you further
comments representative um go ahead um
representative I'd like to ask the
question of the subcommittee um what
harm does this bill do as amended by as
representative musees said does this
bill do any harm would member of the
subcommittee like to address
that it really doesn't um it doesn't
thank you um it doesn't
um um pan out it doesn't offer uh the
positives that it appears so um you know
when you test the drugs um it it's
doesn't lower the overdose um deaths it
doesn't discourage people from even
starting you your their Journey on
substance misuse um we did hear from a
former um drug dealer who is now
performed and he said that he feels that
this is this kind of um law is enabling
um it's really not um it's not as as
wonderful as it appears to be thank you
I would um I would say that um I I I'm
for harm reduction the part of this that
I cannot get by is that it legalizes or
appears to legalize the possession of a
nominal amount of drugs well we look at
the definition of normal amount and it
says 10 Mig of a substance 2 mg of
fentanyl is a lethal dose so this would
allow someone to carry five lethal doses
of fentanyl to go have it tested um so
that that's that's my concern um and
that's the concern I believe of law
enforcement that um and we're sending a
message also that we're condoning this
when we should not be um but we just
passed the test strip bill I I would I'd
like to see how that works before we
pass a second one um I believe let's see
who I wrote down who's in order here
representative nle is
first thank you Mr chair um I just
wanted to well first of all um I was the
sponsor of 287 that is passed um was
signed into law in October um and when
we passed that uh through this committee
it was for testing and analyzing to to
strike testing and analyzing by the
time excuse me by the the time it got to
the Senate and in that uh Committee
hearing um the idea was to restrict it
only to fenel uh test strips which it's
something um but what happened in that
moment we were very lucky um that one of
our uh local ad uh Advocates and and
someone who actually works in harm
reduction New Hampshire harm reduction
Coalition was able to uh I believe it
was that morning the first batch of
xylazine test strips were available and
were delivered to them and she was able
to bring that so that that that could be
added in um that was something that had
just kind of come up on the scene the
reason why I'm I'm talking about this is
to kind of uh bolster representative
Muse's point that we need to be flexible
because we can't always be in that
moment where we're bringing in um you
know last minute oh well we have these
now so we need to add those in there um
these certainly aren't the only things
uh that are are showing up in our drug
Supply and also um to know to what
extent is extremely important fenel is
virtually Ubi ubiquit is right now so if
someone test positive for it there's
value in knowing how much um the other
thing that I wanted to bring up just to
really quickly actually is is um when we
talk about a nom nominal amount I really
wish that we could uh use the language
that was intally uh initially used in uh
Massachusetts what that is is residual
amount but they spef speci ified it more
clearly uh because they wanted to know
it so clearly but but to me not only you
know the very small scoop that you
really uh you know as representative
selig over here needed some my to borrow
my glasses to see to actually see an
indent in this thing it is a very small
amount but really um to visualize it for
myself I think the idea of saying
residuals it is literally what is left
in the bag when everything else is gone
you know um so especially when we use
evidence uh you know like what Oregon uh
I think it's initiative 110 that is
legalizing up to a gram of heroin for
example that is a hundred times what we
are talking about here so you know if we
want to to talk about the evidence and
and you know what draw conclusions from
it um I would number one probably give
it more than a year and then uh number
two uh I would compare apples to apples
and that's just not it's just not the
same thing um so I I would hope that we
could come together around the amendment
um that was very thoughtful and very
responsive and what I felt was a
wonderful compromise uh taking all the
input into consideration I I I really
wish we could uh pass it with the
amendment and to answer your question
representative scitec as a member of the
uh subcommittee no I don't think it does
any
harm if you could um I'd like to ask you
can you add you you kind of touched on
my concern
regarding um nominal but we talked about
you know what you can see and what it
looks like and how tiny that is that's
really irrelevant when we get into
chemical compounds 10 milligrams is
undebatably enough to kill five people
um so why is that level been set at 10
milligrams right representative Muse if
you want whoever feels best get is okay
so the so 10 Mill milligrams if you you
look at the uh Centers for Disease
Control they actually have publication
uh on drug checking um uh 10 milligrams
is the recommended amount um and and
part of that is just a a practical
consideration um 10 milligrams of any
material especially a powder um you're
talking an extremely small amount um uh
and so for example I saw a brochure by a
har reduction group in New York that
basically said it's about the equivalent
if you took if you took had enough
powder to spread on Abraham Lincoln's uh
head on a penny that would be about how
much chemical we're talking about so
when you when you when you realize that
this is a this is a chemical that's
going to be uh probably transported in a
in a plastic bag or in a pill bottle or
or or something like that it's we're
talking an extremely small amount um uh
is 10 milligrams of certain drugs more
than enough to kill you yes it is but
part of part of the issue is you need
also to be a to to actually save lives
um people actually need to be able to uh
uh to be able to to have enough material
to actually do uh a legitimate test they
have to be able to see it um they have
to be able to handle it they actually
have to be able to to do the test so
that's a little bit of the the drug
manufacturers make it a lot easier um if
they package their stuff up in in much
lower concentrations but they don't seem
be to be cooperating and doing it so the
choice that we're left with is either we
have language like this in the bill um
uh or we we kill the bill and and we
lose an opportunity uh to save lives
that we could be we could be saving um
you know this is this is is extremely
frustrating uh because I think on this
committee um more than any other
Committee in the house we hear testimony
around the impact of the drug problem in
New Hampshire and um and I I really
think that here we have an opportunity
um to save lives and we you know a lot
of times we have the opportunity to
punish people more to punish people less
but here we actually have an opportun
to make to make a difference that could
make a huge difference to a lot of New
Hampshire
families thank you um for our members of
the subcommittee I have a question did
anyone um come in to testify and say
that you know I I utilized this testing
before and it saved my life did did we
hear any actual anyone actually even
saved that we know of Representative um
um just a we we it's not legal here well
so no one in New Hampshire would be
coming in to speak on their experience
in New Hampshire since it's just not a a
possibility considering we would be
wanting to pass it I would think that
someone from out of state who who was
interested in it would come testify that
it's working great or at least working
um representative
siling thank you so I I just want to
address a couple of the things that that
have been brought up so first of all
with Oregon Oregon voted to legalize or
decriminalize a huge number of of drugs
that are not legal in New Hampshire so
it's really a non seiter right and and
they aren't writing laws to take away
their testing they're working on trying
to repeal some of their legalization
initiatives I believe and I'm not fully
clear but again it's irrelevant to what
we're doing here um I share
representative Muse's frustration
because we worked very hard in in
subcommittee to take the concerns that
we heard from the initial bill about the
risks of it breaking laws and people
having access and again I brought my
little scoop because I was so teeny I
couldn't believe it um but understanding
um from a scientific perspective you
need a certain amount of material in
order to run a lab test to distinguish
things it's kind of like when you take
your coid test you know it's not just
like stick the swab in your nose and
take it out you have to like actually
move it around to get enough sample for
those tests to work you have to have a
sufficient amount of material to make a
drug test work um but in the last few
weeks I've been reading a lot in the
papers about how um just two days ago uh
the New York Times had an article about
how a number of drug dealers have been
deliberately using um adding things like
meth which is not currently covered by
xylazine strips or feny strips into
their drug supply for the goal of
getting people dual addicted right
without people realizing that's what's
in their drugs the kinds of testing that
could happen as a result result of the
amended version of this bill would allow
someone to have their drug Supply tested
for things like that to make sure
they're not being done things I will say
personally if a drug dealer wanted to
expend the $60,000 to have the kind of
lab equipment necessary to do the type
of drug testing that we're hoping to
legalize to make sure that what they're
selling is cleaner and purer I I
wouldn't personally have a problem with
them doing things to make their supply
safer um because my goal is for people
to live long enough to make the decision
to get themselves clean and I I think
that one of the things that we really
tried to focus on and I know that
representative Muse and N were doing a
tremendous amount of research on to to
ensure was looking at ways to to take
the harm reduction part of this as the
primary focus not decriminalizing
anything it's not saying that people
should be able to go out and sell
spoonfuls of cocaine you know or or
anything else for that matter spoonfuls
of fentanyl it's saying we want to make
places that do drug testing be able to
do the drug testing to protect our
citizens the other thing is there was a
story yesterday I believe it was on um
New Hampshire Public Radio about the
autopsies in the state of New Hampshire
and the fact that we don't have enough
people who are able to perform autopsies
so that we are only having autopsies on
600 of the overdose deaths a year and
that's not even necessarily all that's
they're not even all people who overdose
they're only 600 autopsies being
performed per year in New Hampshire
which is a lot lower than the death rate
which means there's a lot of people who
are dying from suspected overdose where
we don't know what it is they've
overdosed from and we did hear specific
testimony during our subcommittee that
fenel was in our state probably for 20
years before we got fenel test strips
legalized if we could have identified
fenel 20 years ago we might have stopped
a huge number number of people from
dying we might have gotten a lot more
people to work to get themselves cleaner
sooner so I just want us to really think
about um I I I wish the person who
brought forward the itl motion would
withdraw it that we could vote for this
amendment because the amendment really
takes into consideration those legal
concerns the law concerns it really
worked very hard to be very specific
that it is purely for the purpose of
testing drugs to ensure that people
aren't going to die
thank you thank you um just a second um
I just want to be clear the it sounds
like we're saying that testing isn't
won't be done if we don't pass this
however I'm quite sure that every single
arrest the police make the substances
are being sent to the lab and tested so
we know what's in our supply um on a
daily
basis um so at least as far as as far as
the people who are being arrested we
know what the substances are that they
have represent we we heard testimony
that contradicted that when they when
they prosecute someone though they have
to be able to tell them what the
substance
is
zus sorry one of the things that uh uh
Lauren McGinley with the New Hampshire
harm reduction Coalition told us we
asked her specifically about that issue
um and she said sometimes that testing
doesn't happen for
months um so the advantage the advantage
of of of of drug checking and and having
folks in the harm reduction Community
actually empowered to do it is that
information is almost real time you know
you you you understand that a new
contaminant or or some type of an
adulterant has has entered into the
supply um maybe not as soon as it
happens but very very quickly afterwards
as opposed to you know waiting on a
State Police lab and I think if the
state police were here they would
probably tell you you that um their
their processing um is nowhere near
close to real time um because they're
under the same kind of budget
constraints and timing constraints I
think that so many people in law
enforcement are under um so was there
testimony to that effect from the law
enforcement there was test um I'm sorry
that was testimony from Miss McGinley um
did law enforcement testify at this at
the subcommittee representative
tanzar uh no and just to clarify
representative MERS to two separate Labs
the state police crime lab and also
whatever lab the New Hampshire harm
reduction uses there's not there's a
disconnect they don't talk to each other
so yes chairman State Police knows
what's in the system but the harm
reduction might not and then they don't
talk to each other so that's where again
is is a disconnect I hope that
clarified um representative
PR
so two things it was my my impression
that they were only testing to see if it
was an illegal drug they weren't t
testing to see all the other kinds of
stuff that were in it but I could be
wrong the other thing that we heard we
went out or I did anyway went out to the
mobile van that hands out the test
strips uh clean needles bandaging
material and all that stuff and asked do
people actually use these test strips
and and how does that play out and we
were told that some use the test strips
and if there things in there that they
don't like they actually toss that whole
bag of drugs because they just don't
want it and they go look somewhere else
to find a cleaner set of drugs yes I
know it's kind of
enabling but I think you're saving lives
at the same time and again hopefully we
can get better programs that encourage
them to go get clean uh but at least
they'll be alive to do that and may not
have those other consequences that go
with um xylene and the the new one
uh that are causing them sores and other
side effects and maybe even overdosing
them
so I'll tell you I'm really in a quandry
because I'm sitting right on that
fence because I don't want to enable
anybody but I hate to see people die
because I get to see that in the street
quite enough and I'm all set with that
um so if this can save a few lives I I I
think I'm going to pass
it representative Stone thank you Mr
chair I see this as partly being a
problematic for law enforcement to deal
with as well um with law enforcement you
would be looking at uh having discretion
at the the street level you'd have
discretion at the prosecutor level as
well I haven't seen anything that says
that a prosecutor has to bring a case
forward if they they feel there's
competing harms issues I think this is
opening a gateway to possibly more of an
issue for hindering of law enforcement
and saving lives through that
mechanism thank you
um Can someone tell me that the law that
was just signed by the governor what
does that allow
represent so the uh HB 287 what it does
is it literally uh makes an exemption
for feny and xylazine test strips and uh
that is yeah so that's that's all was
what we did was we struck the words they
wanted to make it much more specific and
so that was their uh compromise in
passing the bill okay so representative
Pro to your question the strips you saw
working in saving lives uh currently we
the governor just signed that into law
that we passed in this Committee just
months ago this is a whole new one that
we're going to be discussing and when I
was talking to those people in the van
they said that having a full spectrum
test would be more beneficial because
new and exciting things apparently are
coming and the only way they can do that
is by you not just with a test strip but
having enough that they can put in a
machine and get a full spectrum
so and you know those people are cutting
it with all kinds of
crap that are not beneficial to human
existance D representative Muse I mean
mu Manion thank you Mr chair the
difference with that Is possessing a
test strip to test your drugs versus
this law allowing you to legally possess
a certain amount of illegal drug any
amount of illegal drug being legally
possessed now because of the SL I'm not
for so the difference in the test strip
Is possessing the test strip not a drug
this law will allow up to 10 milligrams
of a drug being possessed now legally so
for that reason I would be uh opposed to
it and to be clear so the test stps
right now if someone decides to go to
the van and utilize it if they happen to
get arrested um they they have no they
can't say well I'm going to get it
tested it's this would enable them to
actually carry an amount around with
them is that correct your understanding
of the
bill one last time I'm sorry the other
thing I forgot to mention we also heard
specific testimony about the extreme
cost cost of um things like xylazine
that if someone ends up with open wounds
from xylazine for example which now we
can test for but um that it was
something like um up to six weeks of
inpatient care and if they don't have
medical insurance that's a cost born by
all of the stakeholders in New Hampshire
um and the medical cost of initially the
emergency room care which I can tell you
emergency room bills are no joke having
just having to negotiate those with
insurance um but a six week stay as an
inpatient to have open wounds treated
and many of these people are having to
come back again and again and some of
these new drugs that we are as yet not
aware what they are because we don't
have a way to test for them legally and
safely um would lead to additional very
high costs for all of us as a taxpayer
that are much higher than the cost it
would be to adopt the amendment test for
these things and try to get them out of
our drug Supply or at least make people
aware that these things are going to
cause much much more serious harms than
they're aware of including our college
students who might be attempting to use
recreational drugs who are too foolish
to know to protect
themselves and where would these um
where would this testing take
place it's in har it we specified
through harm reduction programs
approved but where though where
specifically where it
be
put your mic
on um we actually haven't specified uh
you know a lot of the structure of what
that what that would look like
essentially what we're trying to do in
the bill um is to just make sure that
that people who are engaging in harm
reduction activities currently folks
like the New Hampshire Co uh the New
Hampshire harm reduction Coalition um
don't run a risk of getting arrested for
the good work that they're actually
doing so I think that's one of the one
of the issues that we've also tried to
address in the bill um and I would like
to point out um that um we're not
legalizing possession of 10 milligrams
of of of any substance um you know
essentially what we're doing is that
we're saying within the within the
context of drug checking for the purpose
of drug checking only this this this
amount um
essentially um will be uh you know will
be allowable only in the context of of
of drug checking so if you're if you're
um you know if you're selling it to
somebody else you know for for for
example um it doesn't apply uh one one
of I think one of the somebody during
one of the public hearings raised the
issue of well you know wouldn't uh you
know wouldn't drug dealers start you
know packaging up all of their drugs in
10 milligram bags because it would be
legal and uh you know
no as a practical matter that makes
absolutely no sense uh and and again it
it's just a basic decision I mean
sometimes these are these are some of
the trade offs that we need to make in
order to save lives and uh and one of
the reasons why harm reduction is
catching on all over the country is
because it is working and it is Saving
Lives things like fentanyl test strips
but but the thing is is you know we
can't always be we don't want to be in a
situation where we're two years behind
the drug Supply trying to file
legislation to catch up so the advantage
of passing this bill with the amendment
is we get out of that game we don't have
to do that
anymore you know we we can Empower
people in the harm reduction Community
to do what they do to save lives to use
uh new drug checking technology and
tools as they become available like
fentanyl test strips like new kinds of
test strips that actually will identify
multiple types of compounds that are
that are coming on the market these are
things that you know we're just going to
want people taking advantage of and and
you know the other thing I'd like to
point out is well you know we're all con
a little concerned about uh about
enabling folks um and we'd all like
people to be in recovery instead the the
bottom line is you can't recover if
you're
dead and and I think that's part of the
issue that we're trying to fix
here representative Harry
cther thank you Mr chair um just want to
give a few statistics that came out
yesterday on a report for um Manchester
and nashar year to date through the end
of October AMR Medics have responded to
a total of 802 suspected opioid
overdoses in Nashua and Manchester 614
in Manchester and88 in
nashar 86 of those calls were suspected
opor overdose deaths 53 were in
Manchester and 33 were in
nashille AMR Medics responded to 4
suspected op overdoses in October that
is the highest one month total since
August of
2018 76 suspected opio o overdoses in
Manchester that is the highest 1mth
total since August of
2018 28 suspected opioid overdoses in
nashar that is the highest one month
total since May of
2022 AMR Medics responded to a s
suspected opior deaths in nsha and
Manchester during September eight were
in Manchester three were in
Nashua that these results alone if we
can do anything to save a life we should
be sitting here and signing off on it
right away we should not be hesitating
at all if there's anything that would
save folks life here it could be your
child my child my grandchild or great
grandchild but we're talking about
saving lives here
here and if we have that opportunity we
need to do
that representative
scitech I have a my question is I feel
like I'm at the subcommittee level and I
don't like that is can anyone get high
from these strips under exi from the
strips as in this bill or from your
Amendment representative Ms can you get
high from
these
I'm I'm sure some people would try um
but I don't think that's actually
possible I don't think the question is
um whether they can get high from the
strips it's whether they're getting high
from the from the drugs that they're
actually bringing to to have
tested
um um so try to separate the drug that's
on
thep representative
KH thank you Mr chairman uh Mr chairman
uh my experience with this uh opio
issues that we facing for many years uh
in my town I attended so many funerals
is you know I understand that every
representative will tell me the same
story that what I went through uh I was
not with the U subcommittee or anybody
but what kind of messes we going to send
to our citizens and our society that we
approved we as a legislature approved
some kind of drugs to kill another drug
or
something okay thank you um
representative
Murray thank you Mr chair I mean I think
we need to remember that the War on
Drugs has existed for decades and the
methods we've been using are not working
like representative Harriet G right
mentioned Manchester in October had over
100 opioid
overdoses um related deaths which is the
highest total since 2018 um and I think
it's time we try new methods to try and
slow these deaths so like many people
have said the point is to keep people
alive until they have the ability to
change their behavior and be get in
recovery and I don't think we should be
sentencing people like it feels like
just allowing people to die because of
our own feelings about what we're doing
instead of like the actual
impact would this
law have prevented any overdoses I don't
think that this law would um tells or in
any way would tell someone the amount
they can take that will kill them and
we're already able to test for Fentanyl
and xylazine so what is it that this law
would add that would save a
life that we know of that has been
taken I mean I would say that you know
off sometimes people are overdosing on
something they aren't aware that they're
taking that it's in the substance that
they're using that is um being cut with
something else um and also like other
people have mentioned we have new
substances entering the market all the
time so to wait until we can identify
those substances know that they exist
you know create steps create new
legislation
in all that time we could already have
been testing for those substances before
they reach a point where they're taking
so many lives and I also see this in a
way um at you know it's going to cut
away at the market as well if you think
about the fact that if people start
testing their drugs and they see that oh
if I buy from this seller he cuts with
these things all the time everybody
stops going to that seller like it could
actually cut away at the market in that
way as well as well as um you know
helping people protect themselves
thank you um on the subcommittee can
someone tell me what was the testimony
of law enforcement regarding this
representative um
tzar in the subcommittee we do not have
any no law enforcement so we haven't
heard from law enforcement at all on
this is not at all just from harm
reduction interesting okay all right I
think we there were law enforcement uh
people present but they didn't
change I think that we've had a a
thoughtful um debate and we've we've dug
into this so I'm going to ask the um
clerk to call the role the motion on the
floor is itl I would ask everyone just
to vote your
conscience representative Stone yes
representative maer yes representative
Pratt yes representative
scitec representative PR no
representative Khan yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative tenar yes representative
Gite no representative muse no
representative Vale no representative Su
Newman no representative Murphy no
representative Ray
Newman no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no Representative
selig no representative
wheeler representative
wheeler chair Roy uh chair
yes um
812 represent M would you like to make a
motion I move out to pass with Amendment
second um representative Murphy seconded
that
um what do you
mean
yeah we have a procedural snapu um I
okay I think we have to introduce your
Amendment correct
repres
yeah I introduce uh uh Amendment
2023-24
22h uh to HB 470 FM thank you would you
like to is there I don't think we need a
second on that
um can you speak to your Amendment yes
uh copies of the amendment were
distributed there were also copies of
the amendment over on the table for
folks who uh who do not have them this
is a significant rewrite of the addition
of the original Bill uh so as I said
earlier there were some concerns uh some
very legitimate concerns on the part of
law enforcement that uh by removing L uh
testing and analizing from the drug
paraphernalia law um uh in order to
accommodate things like FAL T Test test
strips uh we also could conceivably be
legalizing the use of that equipment uh
for manufacturing compounding and
distribution which is something we did
not want to do so one of the things that
the amendment does uh is it actually
leaves that portion of the language
intact and then creates specific
exemption uh for drug checking equipment
uh from the drug paraphernalia law um
what it also does is it gets us out of
the game of having to uh every time a
new technology comes along for drug
checking of having to modify our statute
uh so the second part of of that uh of
that exemption uh actually uh opens the
door for uh new drug checking equipment
that comes on the market like
multicompound strips and things like
that uh to be uh to be used without
having to come back to this committee a
couple years from now and try to get us
to pass another law to change our
current law so what it does is it
basically makes uh it it creates a lot
more flexibility for the harm reduction
Community uh to save lives um and
hopefully one of the things that it will
lead to is a lot more of uh of basically
more of this resource being available to
more of the people who need it at a time
when it will actually do them some good
um and as representative Cel said one of
the things that uh that uh it can will
also likely lead to uh in the same way
that legalization of fentanyl test
strips did for compounds that are doing
additional harm uh like uh benzo dipene
uh and LOL and some of the other things
that are now being found in our drug
Supply um injuries um and and and I
would say um unplanned uh interactions
let's say between the drug you think
you're taking and the drug it's been cut
with um that's that's another danger
because benzo dipene we're talking about
uh drugs like resip Pam uh and Valium uh
so those those are drugs if you've ever
seen them most of the time they're in
little little tiny pills um it doesn't
take a lot uh for you know for for uh a
lot of a drug like that either uh to uh
potentially put somebody who's not aware
of what they're taking in you know In
Harm's Way so if you're actually if uh
if people have used one compound before
and um and they've been okay uh the fact
that they think they're just taking that
again but they're also taking lorazapam
or valium or one of the other
benzodiazapine drugs it can have an
unpredictable reaction uh in a lot of
people that can lead uh to a lot more
than physical distress the other thing
that we've done in the in the amendment
itself and and in the bill is we've
actually defined uh harm reduction um uh
We've defined what drug checking
equipment is so we've kind of gone
another Step Beyond uh what uh uh you
know what we did with HB 287 and then
the and another thing that we've done is
we've actually um open the open the door
to allowing uh other opioid reversal
agents other than
nxone um uh so so essentially what what
the what the bill and what the amendment
would do is it would put us in a
situation when when those opioid
reversal agents have been properly
tested and approved to be marketed we
wouldn't have an issue with people
saying yeah but um the lock zone is the
only one that's actually approved for us
to use by Statute so we're going to have
to use that even though it's less
effective on people who've overdosed on
Fentanyl and car fenyl so you know the
the bottom line is is the amendment um
the amendment actually addresses many of
the original concerns of law enforcement
um and and I know that there are issues
with the 10 milligram
with a 10 mgram amount but getting back
to it again I think one one of the
things we've heard in the context of
these bills sometimes is I think we may
have actually started with residual
amount in in in the language uh and then
we went to 10 milligrams as a nom as you
know defining an nominal nominal amount
of 10 milligrams because you know
because folks were saying well how much
is a residual amount you know can you
quantify how much is in a residual
amount and the whole reason for having
residual amount in statute is basically
so you don't have to quantify it so it's
sort of which way which way is it I'd be
happy with it either way as long as we
get the bill
passed further
comment okay um at this time I'll ask
the clerk to call the role on the
amendment we are the vote is on whether
to adopt the
amendment all representative scitec I'm
sorry this is the first we're taking
your word for this that this is what you
say it is this is the first I've seen of
this even even with a speed reading
course I'm not going to read and absorb
all of this I I don't know what to
do if you want to look at any specific
sections on the third page section c
talks about the amount
of the the committee will be in order um
the committee is going to take a um
10-minute break to uh allow
representative and anyone else who wants
to to uh who is not part of the
subcommittee to take a second look at
this
bill my excuse than
move original
bill this is what we change in the
AM that
to representative Roy the members of
have a
High
okay we're back um and I hope everyone's
had time to read the bill reflect on the
bill I don't know that we need further
discussion does anyone wish to make
further comment no I don't think so um
so at this time I would ask the clerk to
call the role the motion is to adopt the
amendment number um 2
422h uh representative scitec um whether
we like the bill or not I would ask that
we pass the amendment because it makes
the bill better you may not like the
bill at all but vote down a better bill
but don't pass or well that's
it call the r please representative
Stone no representative AER no
representative Pratt no representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative Khan no representative
Manion yes representative
Reed
no representative tenar yes
representative GA yes representative
Muse yes representative Vil yes
representative Su Newan yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
cig yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes uh
155 representative Muse would you like
to make a
motion yes Mr chair I move that we uh
pass uh HP 470 uh as amended
second moved and seconded who seconded
represent
Murphy um and with that I would ask the
court to call the
role representative Stone no
Representative maer no representative
Pratt no representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative KH no representative
Manion no representative Reed no
Representative tenar no representative
gather yes representative
Muse yes representative Vale yes
representative Su
Newman representative marfu yes
representative Ray Newman yes clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative selig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair vots no
uh motion is
128 um who will represent Muse will you
be writing the majority report yes I
will and representative tzar will you be
writing The Minority Report yes again
all all reports are due no later than
tomorrow and with that we close the
executive session on HB
470 and with that I will open the
executive session on House Bill
512 representative St um Stone would you
like to make a motion Mr chair i' like
can make a motion to itl HB 512
FN is there a
second representative Pro
second would you like to speak to your
motion Mr chair I would the uh sponsor
of this bill requested that we itl at
the subcommittee uh basically he found
that it created some conflicts with
compliance with ATF on the federal level
if this bill was to go forward on a
manufacturing
standard thank you and just for clarity
the committee this was something
regarding um making firearms that were
made in the Hampshire exempt from
federal laws and the biggest firearm
manufacturing the state was not um
interested in this bill so having said
that um any further
comment seeing none out ask cour to call
the role the motion on floor is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Stone yes representative Mai yes
representative Pratt yes representative
saitech representative appr yes
representative KH yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed
representative tzar yes representative
gather yes representative Muse yes
representative Vil yes representative Su
Newman yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative newel yes
representative selig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman
chair votes yes motion is
unanimous any objection to
consent it goes on consent thank you
with that I close the executive session
on um which one was this HB 512
FN then with that we will open the
executive session on HP 593 relative to
the forfeiture of assets and I am going
to be introducing an
amendment if I can find find
it do you have the
amendment let me see if I can find
it thank
you
um I need a second for the amendment can
you second it second seconded by
representative Manion this amendment um
is brought by the sponsor um what it
does uh well a little back track and we
got an enormous bill um
regarding asset forfeiture and I believe
that the subcommittee and everyone else
who's looked at it thought that it was
much too complex much too many pieces
that didn't belong in this committee
that belong perhaps in
judiciary um and when we got the
amendment the last Amendment it there
just wasn't enough time for us to um
especially given the the amount of
energy and time that was being consumed
by the bail bill for us to delve into
something something like this so he
asked us if we would to just make it a
study committee and then he could work
on it further to perhaps make it ready
that it goes where it should properly
belong once they've figured out what
parts of the bill go where so I would
ask the committee to support um support
making this committee study committee
anyone else wish to talk on the
amendment see none um I'd ask the court
to call the role on adopting the
amendment number 236
4 representative Stone
yes representative maer yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative pu yes
representative KH yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative tenar yes representative
GTH yes representative Muse yes
representative ve yes representative Sun
Newman yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative suig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
motion is
unanimous at this time I would move
ought to pass an amendment
on HB
593 with amendment number 236 for H and
I get a second second second to about
representative Stone um I don't have
anything to add to what I previously did
I just think that this is a complex Bill
although it does it does have some value
it just needs to be further worked on
and I would encourage us to give him the
opportunity to work on that um with that
I would ask cler
Colo representative Stone yes
representative maer yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative PR yes representative KH
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
tenar yes representative
GA representative Muse yes
representative Vil yes representative Su
Newman yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative salik yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
motion is
unanimous any objections to
consent seeing none that will go on
consent hereby close the executive
session
on House Bill 593 has
amended and I'm going to open the
executive session on now bear with me on
this because some of them are out of
order we're waiting on amendments for
some bills
um let's see which one we're ready
for I believe we're ready for
sb49 no um it's 252 that something's
happening yep um would you like to make
a motion representative G right on SP
sp49 that's
magistrates
yes I motion to
um SP 249
y on to
pass second is this an
amendment to introduce the amendment
what amendment well the whole thing is
an amendment
actually you amended the whole bill yeah
you got just an introduce
4618 okay sorry yes you're
correct
um I motion to octop pass for Amendment
SB
249 um and the number is 2461
H and I second
that and would you like to speak to your
Ament
motion this bill established M
magistrates who will assist with the
hearing of Baal the issuance of warrants
and other judicial functions the bill
further makes various changes to the
standards governing the release of
individuals on bail pending resolutions
of criminal
cases
um one of the key points in here in the
case of a person arrested when the court
is not open within the next 24 hours a
decision on bail shall be made made by a
magistrate within 24 hours of the
arrest so if you guys remember we had a
lot of
um conversation
about weekend bail and how long a person
could be possibly would be held up to 72
hours and things of that nature so what
we've asked now is that we have 15
magistrates that will um be a part of
each County one Magistrate County and
that that person would be available um
on the weekend so on Friday if someone's
arrested um they can see a magistrate on
Saturday on Saturday or Sunday if
they're arrested on Saturday otherwise
they wouldn't have to wait till the next
um court date to
um have the either given bail or or the
decision to detain them one way or the
other
the other thing that was in here that I
thought was
important so the only difference in as
in this bill when it when it look when
we look at um chapter
491b is that any place that you might
have seen Court the word Court we now
add court or
magistrate uh another thing if there's a
probable cost believe that person is on
release pending resolution of a previous
offense and thereafter was arrested and
released pending the resolution of a
second offense and has committed an
additional Class A misdemeanor or
driving or operating while imp appearer
the person shall be detained for no more
than 24 hours for a bail hearing before
a magistrate or the
court upon appearance in front of a
magistrate or the court for a person
detained under this section there shall
be a rebuttable presumption that the
person will not abide by a condition
that the person not commit a new
offense that's it for me thank you um I
think it's important for everyone to
realize that each of these um bills does
a different thing within the bail system
um and they are integral to each other
but yet separate enough that we felt
that it was important to keep them um on
their own Standalone the magistrates for
example
is a very significant change to the
court system um and we did this in
conjunction with and conferring with the
courts this is not something we're
putting on them this is something that
they agreed to as a matter of fact the
language is almost exactly what they
requested um when they worked with
representative gath a few years back so
um as part of that we implement the
magistrates there'll be one for every um
County and plus an extra couple to for
floating um they going to help out with
other issues the court besides just this
so it's a good investment it will help
take the burden off the Circuit Court
judges and it will also ensure that
people um have a speedy uh bail hearing
um what's important also is that we
changed the law in several of these
bills to make to tighten up um the bail
statute a bit so that people that are
definitely threats to society aren't
just getting out right away um so we've
made some clarifications to the existing
law and the magistrates make that
possible for example if you are arrested
um and we're going to talk about it one
of the other bills for certain offenses
um it's the wish that they not be heard
right away by a bail commissioner that
they be um if it happens during a
weekday they're held and then they go to
the judge in the morning but so that
they're not held over a long weekend the
magistrates will be able to step in and
hear those um for the weekend so some no
one no one has to sit for more than 24
hours without at least someone um laying
eyes on their case and making a a
determination on their bail the version
that we got from the Senate um of the
bill we're about to discuss next did not
allow that people were just going to be
held um from when they were arrested
until they were made made in front of
the court so we've made a significant
change in both directions but the
magistrates are key to making it all
work um so any further comment or
questions about this
representative
Newman I just have a question about the
interaction here between magistrates and
bail Commissioners so if we pass this
law as a
separate bill with magistrates with
requirements in there and there's no
mention of bail Commissioners in here I
don't
believe and we don't have those
magistrates in place by the
implementation date of this
law what effect does that have on bail
Commissioners um we we've I believe we
allowed it least six months yeah and
it's in it's in the bill where is it in
the
bill we talk about the Commissioners in
318 remember oh in the separate bill
yeah again it's addressed in a separate
bill so that all this works together
and yeah and we give it a year this bill
um the effective date of this bill is
January 1
2025 um so there's plenty of time for
them to implement the
magistrates any further questions or
comments seeing none I would ask the
clerk to call the role in the adoption
of the
amendment representative Stone yes
representative maer yes representative
Pratt yes representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative KH yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
repres representative tanzar yes
representative gther yes representative
Muse yes representative Veil yes
representative Su Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative
wheeler chairman Roy chair yes motion is
unanimous would you like to make another
motion representative G
make motion that um art to pass is
amended I second that motion um does
anyone else want to make any further
comment okay then I would ask the clerk
to call the role on a to pass with
Amendment for S
sp49 representative Stone yes
representative maer yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative PR
yes representative Khan yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative tenar yes
representative gri yes representative
Muse yes representative Vil yes
representative Su Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler yes
okay chairman Roy chair yes motion is
unanimous any object to consent seeing
none it will be on consent with that I
close the public hearing on HB 249
excuse me the executive session hb2
249 and open the executive session on HB
318 and I will make a motion to adopt
amendment number 246 zero H can I get a
second second seconded by representative
here gaite and I will speak to the
motion uh this bill is another portion
of the change we made relating to the
bail um
statutes in this one I'll I'll read the
substantial changes um it says any case
where an offender has been arrested for
a crime of violent against an individual
person including an act of stalking a
criminal threat and the bill commission
determines that the offender may be
released pending Tri the arresting
agency will attempt to contact the
victim what we did there is we said if
someone is arrested for a crime of
violence against a person there is a
victim the police will make an effort to
contact that person to notify them that
the offender is being released at least
one hour prior to his release um that
does not mean they can be held until
they find the person that just means
that they have an hour to notify them
before they release the person um the
per the victim has to give the police
their in contact information and they
just have to make a good effort to
notify them and if they can't at the end
of the hour they have to leave a written
notification or send them a voicemail or
something and document the fact that
they notified them I think too often
we've heard stories of people getting
out and a victim being surprised by the
person showing up um and this is an
attempt to help alleviate that um the
bill
also talks about um bail Commissioners
appointments um
it says that uh currently bail
Commissioners we know how they're
appointed but there was no mechanism for
removal of the bail commissioner this
simply adds that the Chief Justice can
for cause remove a bail commissioner um
this was from the court um also the
Chief Justice Superior Court um this is
going to cause them to have
identification cards it was already in
statute that they be provide
identification what we heard in
testimony and subcommittee is that what
they got was an email with a PDF
attachment to print out and that was
their identification um and we did not
believe that was the intent of the
legislation originally and we made it
clear now that we would like them to
actually have an physical card ID with
their picture on it and we authorize the
court to enter into an agreement with
the DMV much as the house does for our
own
identifications um so that they have a
proper
identification this bill further let me
just see if there's anything else we
changed it talks about training we heard
a lot during the um sub committee that
training was an issue for the bail
Commissioners it was hit or miss some of
them got really great training some of
them just kind of met for half an hour
and talked and didn't get any training
at all um so what this does it
standardizes it for new bail
Commissioners they have to have at least
16 hours of training um and for annual
training they have to have at least
eight hours of training and that has to
be documented and this is again where
the magistrates will come in as far as
being um ensuring that the training for
bail Commissioners happens um now we
have someone we know who we can ask
about it um also we raised the bail fee
the bail fee was $40 and has been for a
significant amount of time and we felt
that because of the mileage that and the
cost of gas nowadays um they don't get
paid for that so you get called out at
3:00 in the morning you have to go bail
someone you may have to drive 20 miles
30 miles depending on who's on that
night that you could would be driving a
significant distance there's no
compensation for that and to add insult
to injury some of them weren't being
paid at all we heard testimony in
subcommittee about some bail
commissioner one bail commissioner was
owed over
$50,000 in back bail um now we
understand that we are a volunteer
community and us at these tables here
we're not working it for the money
either and neither are the bail
Commissioners but at some point it
becomes ridiculous and when you're owed
$50,000 uh I think that something needs
to be done
there was a commission in 2018 that made
significant reforms to bail and one of
their recommendations was the court pay
the bail Commissioners directly so we um
looked at that again and we found the
yes they were correct however this time
instead of just suggesting it we are
going to make it law so the court will
be under this bill responsible for
paying the bail Commissioners monthly
for the bails they issued in the
previous month at $50 each it allows the
court to collect the money back from the
defendants if they're not Indigent uh it
allows the court to set their own
standard of indigency and it gives them
uh it allows them to um set in place a
time period of up to a year to repay
that I think most people can come up
with $50 in a year um so U it it
balances indigency with the right of the
people not to have to pay with their
taxes for everybody's bail um I think
that's a fair balance that we struck and
I believe that covers everything
representive gath right did I miss
anything um no I I think you did a great
job I do want to say that I remember
doing testimonies when they talked about
most of them have laptops but they've
actually paid for them themselves so you
know the fact that you know State's
going to actually be paying them
hopefully that would help with that
situation that they have purchasing
their own laptops that's absolutely true
um it's possible to do that job that we
heard um with just your paperwork and uh
but it makes it extremely difficult to
keep track of you know uh many of them
have invested in technology some of them
have to put in phone lines computer
lines things of this nature there's no
reimbursement for that whatsoever so we
felt that the least we could do is
ensure they get paid for the bailes and
it was done in a timely
fashion and I think that's all um any
questions or comments representative
scitec I'm a bail commissioner and I'm
participating I'm not sure what that
means
did you I'm not sure what that
means making a statement that you're
participating yes oh okay um any further
questions or
comments seeing none I would ask the
clerk to call the role on the adoption
of amendment number
246h representative Stone yes
representative maer yes representative
Pratt yes representative ative scitec
representative PR yes representative KH
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
tenar yes representative gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Veil yes representative Su Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
cig yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes motion is
unanimous I would make a motion of ought
to pass with
Amendment have a
second seconded by representative here
gther um I don't need to add anything do
you need to add anything representative
G
right um with that I would ask the CK to
call the role is all the passes
amended representative Stone yes
representative Mai yes representative
Pratt representative
scitec representative pu yes
representative KH yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative tzar yes representative
Gite yes representative Muse yes
representative veale yes representative
Su Newman yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative suig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
motion is
unanimous the motion carries um
unanimously any objection to consent
seeing none it will go on consent and
with that I close the public excuse me
the executive session on which one did
we just do HP
318 and let me see what we have
left yeah I'm trying to find it
does everyone have a copy of 653 no what
I don't
have have one for
252 that's the one I'm waiting for an
amendment on so 653 is the only other
one that we have to work on besides
252 no one has
653 all right we're going to take a just
five minutes where we get copies of the
amendment for everybody I thought they
were were passed out you have
653 is there are there any Brad is there
any over there 653 could could you ask
please if if we could get I don't know
how many copies we
need yeah we're going to take five
minutes we doing what we
just no
what it's it's not improved until we
vote it through right I think that's
what all of them they send us said
that it was
really I think it's unapproved until we
approve it need
someone
okay just to update um Karen is getting
us copies of 653 and we will be taking
that up in about a couple minutes when
she comes back down there is an
amendment to 252 we're waiting on and
that may take a few more minutes so we
will probably end up doing is breaking
for a short Lunch Period after we take
up
at this point everyone should have a
copy of um HB 653 Amendment 2465 does
everyone have
one okay at this point I will make a
motion and offer amendment number
24658 to HB
653 and can I get a second seconded by
representative Harry gaite and I will
speak to my
motion um what we've done with hb6
653 this was as you can see originally a
bill that was intended to prohibit um PR
bail for certain crimes we have um
changed it
significantly um it still is related to
bail however um what it does is it tells
um there right now there's a commission
um it's called the interbranch uh
criminal justice and juvenile law
commission and it's made up of Judges um
County attorneys defense attorneys um
Attorney General's office
Representatives senators and they're the
ones who came together in 2018 and came
up with the bail um statute as it is now
that we're currently amending a little
bit um we're retasking them since rather
than create a new commission um since
they still exist we're going to retask
them and um part of the things we're
going to ask them to look into specific
things to recommend legislation on that
require a a more in-depth um look than
just we were able to do in as a
committee or subcommittee so the first
thing we're asking them to do is
pre-trial Services pre-trial Services um
provide significant um benefits and cost
savings to counties if they're able to
get them up and running they allow um
interventions that keep people out of
incarceration but yet are able to
protect the public and help the the
offender if they're involved with
substance abuse or mental health issues
we heard testimony from the county um
jails that they are they are overloaded
with people with mental health issues
and as a committee we agree that that
mental the judicial system especially
the criminal judicial system is not
designed nor do we want it to deal with
mental health issues um that being said
that is causing a a a lot of um people
to be placed in in Lockup in the jails
and they're not getting the necessarily
the treatment they need so a pre-trial
system um we we heard from several
counties I believe marac was one that
had a really good pre-trial system in
place and um they in Stratford County
and I believe
um no it was the one out west um
Jennifer's jesher County have also have
one um each of them differ a little bit
um but what we would like to do is
have this commission look at this and
say okay what is the gold standard for a
pre-trial Services most other states
have pre-trial
Services um and it saves money as I said
because when they have it and they don't
have to incarcerate people right away
some people that go in there with mental
health issues their medication sometimes
can run up to $330,000 a month and the
Count's on the hook for that um and the
state doesn't give them any money so
what we're doing is we're overburdening
our County Jail systems by having them
hold medical patients in effect and and
that's just not what we want to do so a
pre-trial system would be able to help
get people the mental health they need
without necessarily incarcerating them
um and we think that that's a good thing
so we would ask them to look into it and
establish a gold standard that would be
a model for the state and perhaps
establish a fund that counties could
apply to if they develop a pre-child
system that meets a minimum standard set
um so that incentivizes counties to
develop pre-trial systems and it
incentivizes them to develop um Good
Ones based on this gold standard and we
realize that not every County will need
all the services that are there so we
asking the commission to look at
specifically which ones would be most
important for all of them to have and
then ones that are good to have um so
the next thing that we would be asking
the commission to do would be to um look
at our computer system in the courts and
what we've heard was that from all over
the state the courts kind of have their
own thing in different courts some of
them have really modern um case tracking
some of them have none if you want to do
any research to go to a court and say
I'd like to know how many people have
been convicted of X or how many people
took this type of plea or what was the
outcome of this you would have to
literally almost drive to every Court in
the state to figure that out and in this
age that is not okay um we should be
able to be able to get information so
that we can make laws that are based on
actual facts and not on anecdotes and we
feel that also updating them would
insist with bail um having accurate
information that's up toate real time so
there's a desperate need for our court
system to be modernized and this
commission would be study uh tasked with
studying out how to do that and what it
would cost and figuring out legislation
that would implement it and finally um
victim witness Services um we heard that
most counties do have some type of
victim witness service and we want to
recognize that however there are some
that have not the same level of services
available or only available to certain
victims of certain crimes um the
Attorney General's office has a very
good victim witness service program and
we want to recognize that so we would
ask that this commission look and set a
some type of a standard um for victim
witness Services across the state so
that victims of crimes are equally um
thought of and taken care of the same
way that we spend a lot of time and
money taking care of defendants um often
in these conversations victims get lost
and we want to make sure that they are
offered the proper support after being a
victim of a
crime and I believe that was it oh we
made one more change we heard from
everyone that was involved um that there
was issues that commission when it did
the bail um there was a judge in charge
of the commission um and they asked
specifically that we put the chair of
Criminal Justice Committee in charge of
the commission because they felt that um
as its job is to suggest legislation it
should be a legislator in charge of the
commission because that person will know
um the makeup of the
house what is feasible what is not
feasible and they would easily be able
to get sample legislation drawn up um
they were apparently issues with um the
way it was shared before and I'm not
sure what they are but this was what
they asked for so that's what we had um
and that's it that 653 is merely making
um tasking that commission with looking
into things for us does anyone have any
questions about that or comments would
you like this comment represent of G
frame I think you excellent okay
um seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role on the adoption of the
amendment representative Stone yes
representative maer yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative pu yes representative
Khan yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
tar yes representative Gite yes
representative Muse yes representative
van
yes representative Su Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes representative Newell yes
the clerk votes yes representative suig
yes representative wheeler yay chairman
Roy chair vot yes motion is
20 um I would make a motion of ought to
pass an amendment for HB
653 there a second please
second represent wheeler seconding it
down
um I don't think I need to discuss that
um we we pretty much explain what it
does unless someone has something to say
I would ask the clerk to call the
role representative Stone yes
representative Mai yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative PR yes representative con
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
tenar yes repres representative G yes
representative
Muse yes representative veale yes
representative Sunan yes representative
Murphy yes representative Ruan yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative selig yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chair votes yes motion is unanimous any
objection consent seeing none it will go
on consent um so the last bill we have
to take take up for today unfortunately
is House Bill excuse me Senate Bill
252 and we are as we speak waiting on a
final Amendment um alls has had it for
about 15 minutes 20 minutes um and they
are working on it so at this point I'm
going to have to take a probably let's
just take 30 minutes let's meet back
here at
1:15 um and hopefully it we'll be here
by then or at least I'll have an update
and if it's going to be much longer
we'll consider taking it up at another
time but I'd prefer to have this done
today so um
115 okay 130 you have enough time for
lunch
1:30
e
okay we are back um with the final bill
for today that we are going to be
considering at this point I I would um
make a motion
to bring in amendment number 20 excuse
me 2470 h2b 252 can I get a second
second seconded by representative
gathright I'll speak to my motion this
amendment um this is really the meat and
potatoes of lot most of the work we did
over the
summer it does a number of things um I'm
going to hit on the most important um of
those a lot of them are minor changes
that are just really technical language
changes but the bigger ones are we've
taken the list of crimes that the senate
had proposed if you recall last year um
we've adopted the list however we've
limited it to the felony versions of
those crimes because the list of crimes
they gave um also included misdemeanor
versions so we felt that if a person was
going to be detained and held to be
either see a a m istate or a judge that
it should be a
felony um so we adopted
those and we also changed the the
standard of evidence um we heard from uh
the County attorneys that it was often
difficult to get someone held on
dangerousness because the standard was
um clear and convincing evidence which
is a fairly high standard we recognize
that a person um being held there's a
difference between the level of proof
needed to arrest someone and the level
of proof to hold someone and it's two
different things so what we've done is a
compromise we've we've moved it from
substantial evidence then we started we
went back to probable cause and then we
realized that was probably too low
because it's the exact standard for the
for the crime we've struck middle ground
and I'm happy to say that the standard
would be substantial evidence
substantial evidence is more than
probable cause but less than clear and
convincing evidence so it makes it have
a fair Fair hearing and there's still a
good level of proof needed but it it's
not something that they can't reach um
keeping in mind as we discussed that
it's within 24 hours of arrest so a case
isn't going to be fully developed in
that time to reach a higher standard so
we feel like this was a good compromise
um let me see what else did we do on
this
one we talk about electronic
monitoring if someone is this is this
got the one with the
hold on a
second releasing
the okay if someone's charged with a
violation of of a protective order um
the only way they can be released by the
judge is with a electronic monitor so
this is protecting our domestic violence
victims um someone gets arrested the a
protective order is issued they go out
they violate that protective order by
contacting a victim or any of the number
of ways they can the court can still
release them but at that time they need
an electronic monitoring to be
released
um what
else representative GA would you
anything you want to add that in well
I'm looking to see if we missed
anything have
authority the cour should have the
authorities stud a cash bail amount only
if it is an amount which the defendant
is able to meet yes we uh we continue to
maintain the the proposition that cash
bail um should only be used if someone
can actually pay it the idea of cash
bail is to get incentive for someone to
return to court by setting a bail that
someone could never meet it really is no
incentive it's while it is is just
saying I'd rather hold them so we want
them if they're dangerous hold them for
being dangerous if they're a Flight Risk
hold them for a Flight Risk do not
substitute make making a tough decision
by using cash bail cash bail is only if
someone can afford it and then they want
to come back so that they don't lose the
cash setting a bail that someone can't
pay really is is all it's doing is
holding
them um and that just really expounds
what was already in the statute it just
clarifies
it um the indigeny is the electronic
monitoring um we also enable the court
to be able to allow up to a
year to pay it back we I think we
discussed that
earlier I think that's all is there
anything else I'm missing anyone from
the
subcomittee yeah and what line are you
on well let's see I don't know where the
new one is I know where the old one was
the old one was in the area of 31 31 the
new one one was supposed to be on page
three right okay if if you're looking
for the warrant part it's page four um
paragraph B There we
go page four paragraph two okay
paragraph D yeah we added paragraph D
unless um a search warn is obtained law
enforcement is not able to get the uh
information so another words if the
court orderers somebody to be put on
electronic monitoring because they
violated their protective order terms
the police aren't able to call them and
say hey can you tell me if this guy was
also at the 7-Eleven today at 12 um and
use that as a uh grounds to build a case
against them they have to get a search
warrant to get that information the idea
behind this is to further protect the
victim and help ensure that the
defendant is living within the terms of
his conditions and the order not to just
open up him to tracking
247 and I think that's
it anyone else wish to speak um
representative here G would you like to
address
this oh no I thought we just addressed
it
okay I have a question um about the
1A uh there
is the question I have is the cash bail
amount only if an amount which the
defendant is able to meet there are
circumstances where you might this is
unusual but it's possible they have the
money but they can't get it because
they're in they're in
custody what do we do with somebody who
can meet it but they're in custody and
can't get
to can't can't tap their
resources and just no he's talking about
setting the bail um so you're you're
saying if you're you're setting bail on
someone and they have the ability to pay
the cash bail but they're unable to get
it because they're incarcerated yeah
yeah that that is a bit of a conundrum
um I what you do now yeah what do you do
currently
um they're they've got to come up with
it they got to get their wife they have
to do it yeah because we know that if
they have it they'll find a means to get
it but I'm not sure if that continues
here that's I would say that it does
that it I don't I think that the the
legislative intent throughout the bill
is that to not use C it specifically
even says do not set cash bail that they
can't afford to pay because that's not
why we're so to say that they can't meet
it physically because they forgot their
wallet at home I don't think that that I
think that would be a significant
stretch for the court to all right that
that's my question but it's reasonable
if it does happen but I think that the
our intent in this legislation is very
clear if someone has the money it
doesn't necessarily mean has it on their
person so any other
questions all right seeing none I'll ask
the clerk to call the role in the
adoption of the
amendment representative Stone yes
representative maer yes representative
Pratt yes representative
citec representative PR yes
representative con yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative tenar yes
representative gther yes representative
Muse yes representative Vil yes
representative Su Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chairs yes 20 at this time
I would move a to pass an amendment on
s252 as Amendment second seconded by
representative gaite I think we've
discussed this I would ask the clerk to
call the
role representative Stone yes
representative Maser yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative PR yes representative
Khan yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
tenar yes representative gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Vil yes representative Sue Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chotes yes 20 and it's
passed unanimously no objection to
consent and going on consent I wish to
congrats everyone this is um this is a
result of 5 months of work by
subcommittee take a
go um this was truly a bipartisan effort
that we went back and forth literally
until the last minute and um I'm proud
of everybody and um let's keep going now
we we can take a short break uh tomorrow
morning we have a public hearing on a
non- gerain amendment I really
anticipate this should be short the
County Attorney is going to come address
him we're going to hear him and we're
going to execute right away um so thank
you all very much and I will see you
tomorrow can I say thank you as well
thank you for this whole entire team
here I just have been amazed to be
honest with you after being here for
eight years and working with this group
of Criminal Justice Public Safety people
I just want to say thank you for being
understanding and trying to be a team
that was more important y I agree whole
hard to thank you just a reminder for
the reports to get them into the chair
tonight uh no by tomorrow um if you can
do it tonight great but by tomorrow
latest on the
reports